hacia un desbloqueo de los puertos
ucranianos
rusia quien tiene bajo su control dos de
los marcadores más importantes de
ucrania en el mar de azov busca liberar
alimentos que han estado represados en
la nación bajo ataque desde el 24 de
febrero se ha completado el desminado
del puerto de mariupol está funcionando
normalmente y ha recibido sus primeros
buques de carga además el puerto
marítimo de verdi ans ya está en
funcionamiento los envíos de cereales
están listos para reanudarse en estos
puertos a la orden del comandante en
jefe supremo
ucrania es el tercer exportador mundial
de trigo y el cuarto para el maíz y
ocupa al menos el 50 por ciento de los
comercios de semillas y aceite de
girasol
se estima que como consecuencia de la
guerra unas 20 millones de toneladas de
grano están estancadas en los puertos
ucranianos lo que ha provocado un alza
generalizada de los precios a nivel
mundial y temores de hambruna en los
países más dependientes de las
importaciones
occidente ha acusado a rusia de utilizar
el bloqueo de los puertos como un arma
de guerra
las dramáticas consecuencias de la
guerra de rusia se están extendiendo por
todo el mundo y esto estaba haciendo
subir los precios de los alimentos
empujando a la gente a la pobreza y
desestabilizando regiones enteras rusia
es la única responsable de esta crisis
alimentaria food crisis rusia lun
entre tanto rusia ha suspendido la
retoma de las exportaciones al
levantamiento de las sanciones impuestas
por occidente como consecuencia de la
invasión y turquía se ha planteado como
mediador en el proceso de negociaciones
para la retoma de las exportaciones tema
central de la esperada visita del
ministro de exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov ankara antes de la invasión rusia
ucrania exportaba 6 millones de
toneladas de grano cada vez su capacidad
actual es de apenas 2 millones y las
autoridades advierten que aunque se
levantarán los bloqueos de rusia le
tomaría al país al menos seis meses
desminar las aguas del mar negro así las
cosas la escasez de los granos rusos y
ucranianos y sus consecuencias para el
mundo parece inevitable en el mediano
plazo